an update on some breaking news and
france germany and
italy have now joined the eu countries
to suspend
the roll out of the oxford astrazeneca
covid vaccine the head of the oxford
vaccine group
has reassured the public over its use
following reports of serious blood
clotting in four patients in norway the
french president emmanuel macron
has said the european watchdog will
issue a ruling on the oxford jab
tomorrow our science correspondent
thomas more joins me now
that list of countries suspending the
use of the vaccine for now getting
longer
thomas what's happening
which around a dozen countries around
the world that have suspended the
vaccine or suspended certain batches of
the vaccine
and it does all boil down to this link
with blood clots
now there have been a number of people
who have suffered blood clots
deep veins from boces and also clots in
the lung
after they've been vaccinated and there
have been
some of those that have died now
what isn't clear though that these were
actually caused by the vaccine and
that's why the european
medicines agency is looking at the
evidence it does seem to be
coming down to the statistics at the
moment and the
ema has said that so far out of five
million people to have had the vaccine
across the continent there have been
30 reports of blood clots now in a
population of that size
you'd expect one in a thousand or around
100 a week developing a blood clot
even without vaccination so you can see
why many experts will say well there
just isn't any evidence that is the
vaccine
that is causing this that it could be
many other reasons other medical
conditions
that people would naturally have and
just because there is this temporal
association with vaccination doesn't
mean that the vaccine caused it and
certainly the world
health organization is extremely
concerned that there is a bit of a
bandwagon now that people are
countries are pausing their vaccinations
uh waiting to see what happens when in
fact
people are dying from kovid every day so
this
link is leading to people giving up on a
vaccine which has a known
beneficial effect so the prime minister
also
in the uk has said that there's no
evidence to be concerned about here in
the uk that the rollout here in the uk
will continue
that every confidence in the safety and
the effect
of the astrazeneca vaccine